So this video that I'm going to show you is
truly, genuinely delightful.
It is some old fashioned face planting and
it all happened on Fox News.
You probably heard by now Donald Trump's rally
in Tulsa, Oklahoma, where he expected 60000
people for which they believe they received
the million ticket requests they had.
Sixty two hundred people show up, according
to the fire department.
So here's video of two different Trump Tool's
who went on Fox News, who had no way to explain
what happened other than to completely collapse.
And it's just a pleasure to watch.
This is total schadenfreude, and I completely
admit it.
It is taking pleasure in the failure of others,
but it is pleasure for the greater good.
If nineteen thousand people had shown up,
if sixty two thousand people had shown up,
it would have been a disaster in terms of
corona virus spread.
We should all be glad.
From a public health perspective that only
sixty two hundred people showed up.
So here's the first video.
This is Mercedes Schlapp, a Trump campaign
senior adviser.
Watch and Enjoy campaign said that more than
a million people wanted tickets for this rally.
But we all saw the pictures last night.
The arena was no more than two thirds full
and the outdoor rally that had been planned
for the overflow crowd was canceled because
there was no overflow crowd.
Question what happened?
Well, first of all, thank you for having me,
Chris, and happy Father's Day to you.
Let me explain.
When it comes to understanding how the rallies
work, it's a first come, first serve basis.
Basically what the one million RSVP is include.
It's an opportunity for us to gather data,
to get information, obviously.
So the key here is that that is important
is to understand that I had this with my own
personal family who lives not far away from
Tulsa, that they were concerned.
There were factors involved, like they were
concerned about the protesters who were coming
in.
There were protesters who blocked the bags.
And so we saw that have an impact in terms
of people coming to the rally.
But what was amazing, Chris, was the fact
that over five point three million people
watched it on all of our digital media channels.
And so the reach was far and wide.
And that doesn't even include the TV numbers.
We also did a pre rally show and that was
over two million views.
So, you know, we're living in a virtual time.
Our site is a Mercedes, a Mercedes, if I can
guess.
The fact is the president talks about the
attendance at his events.
As we all know, that he made a big.
Yes, of the attendance at his inauguration,
he talks about how you can fill in an arena
and that Joe Biden can't.
He didn't fill the arena last night.
And you are off and let me, if I may finish
and you guys were so far off that you had
planned an outdoor rally and there wasn't
an overflow crowd.
And I have been watching the coverage and
talking to Mark Merideth on the ground today.
Protesters did not stop people from coming
to that rally.
The fact is, absolutely they did.
I can tell you there were people I'm telling
you there were people and families that didn't
want and couldn't bring their children because
of concerns of the protesters.
Oh, it was first come, first served.
So then it wasn't a completely embarrassing
failure.
So, you know, again, with the protesters silly
liberal snowflakes apparently scared off these
rugged conservatives from seeing their lord
and savior in person doesn't sound like the
alpha behavior that they claim to exhibit,
does it?
That that's your best argument.
So now the issue isn't so much how many went,
but she makes it about how many people watched.
And of course, a ton of people were watching
for the comedic and dystopian elements.
There were a ton of streams from the left
ridiculing the entire thing.
And again, to believe that if a million people
wanted to go and only 60, 200 showed up, we're
supposed to believe that ninety nine point
four percent of the people that wanted to
go were scared off by liberals.
What phatic argument to be making.
And then you might have noticed that she went
into attacking Biden, saying, look, Biden's
not bringing huge crowds.
Biden isn't doing any big events.
Biden doesn't claim that he's never had an
empty seat at every event that he does.
Biden is being responsible in the context
of the Corona's by Corona virus pandemic because
some statistically people are going to die
because of that rally.
The rally was held.
There will be some contagion that happens
that otherwise wouldn't and some fraction
of those people are going to die.
Fortunately, it will be fewer than if there
had been nineteen thousand or sixty two thousand
people there.
Just hilarious.
And then here's another one named Janet Ellis.
She's a senior legal adviser to the Trump
2020 campaign.
She says thousands of people were turned away,
which is sort of neither here nor there.
But what I love in this clip is she says,
look, thousands of people turned out four
hours earlier.
They were talking about a million ticket requests.
And now she's bragging that thousands showed
up.
Take a look.
Not at all.
This was a wonderful attendance.
And we're so proud of all of the great American
patriots who showed up and thousands to support
the president and his first rally in over
three months.
And listen, the fact that there were so many
obstacles to overcome to even get into the
BRCA center there, and still we had over 6000
people plus thousands more outside that were
turned away.
This was an incredibly strong event.
And I think that this is the most hilarious
goalpost move that I've maybe ever seen.
A million people supposedly requested tickets.
We had thousands of people show up.
That's a huge, huge success.
What a victory.
You got trolled, including by what it seems
were just teenagers requesting tickets on
the Internet.
You would almost feel bad for these people
for looking so dumb on national television.
And then you remember they're choosing to
show up and be interviewed and defend this
total failure.
They're choosing to work with the reelection
campaign of Donald Trump.
And this gets us back to an important reminder.
Rally crowds don't win elections.
Whether Trump had sixty two hundred or six
hundred and twenty or sixty two thousand or
six hundred and twenty thousand people show
up.
Rally crowds don't win elections.
If rally crowds won elections, Bernie Sanders
would currently be the Democratic nominee.
There's one race that matters, and it's how
many people vote in November.
And you've got to do it.
Figure out what's going on with vote by mail
and absentee.
Figure out which polling places are being
closed down.
We'll talk about that in the context of Kentucky's
primary election tomorrow.
Figure it all out, because that's really the
only thing that matters.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
We now have a video that is going viral.
It's going ultra viral of me making a meal
that I grew from scratch in my backyard.
OK, everything that I eat in this meal is
kind of a joke, but you've got to look at
it for yourself.
I grew myself in my backyard, harvested, prepared
myself.
OK.
That's David Pakman show on Instagram.
Don't miss it.
Let me know what you